>>Female Presenter: Good afternoon and welcome.
It's an honor and a privilege for me today
to introduce one of the world's greatest contemporary
artists and Seattle native son, Dale Chihuly.
Dale has popularized and revolutionized the
Studio Glass Movement, bringing this new American
art to international fame.
His work is included in more than 200 major
museum collections, which has to be pretty
close to setting the record for number of
installations for a living artist as he's
exhibited in numerous prestigious museums
and galleries all over the world, such as
the Victoria and Albert Museum in London and
other exhibitions, including Chihuly in the
Light of Jerusalem, which broke a record for
a million visitors.
He's also well-known for his garden installations.
He studied here at University of Washington,
the University of Wisconsin-Madison, and Rhode
Island School of Design.
And he's been the recipient of many awards,
including eleven honorary doctorates and two
fellowships for the National Endowment of
the Arts.
Dale and his team, working in a boathouse
by the water here in Seattle, continue to
push the limits of glassblowing craftsmanship
and glass art.
And I have to say, it was seven years ago
I was lucky enough to get to visit the boathouse
here in Seattle.
And I was there with my mother.
And as we left, I think we drove about five
blocks without saying anything.
And then, my mother stopped and said, "That
is the closest experience anyone will ever
have to being at Giverny with Monet when he
was painting the water lilies."
[laughs] She said it was just amazing to be
with an artist of that caliber and quality
and inspiration while he's doing some of the
best work of his career.
And the most amazing part of all of this is
that Dale is opening his own garden here in
Seattle next month.
And he's gonna give us an overview of that
exhibit.
It's Chihuly Garden and Glass.
And after that, we'll also be joined by his
wife, Leslie Chihuly, and Michelle Bufano
for some questions.
And with that, Dale Chihuly.
[applause]
>>Dale Chihuly: Thank you.
Leslie and I are happy to be here and we're
going to give you a little sneak preview of
Chihuly Garden and Glass.
I'm gonna start with a seven-minute video
that will give you a history of my work.
So, if we could queue that up.
[pause]
[plays video]
>>Dale Chihuly: I've often been asked what
would I like to do that I haven't done.
And the first thing that comes to mind is
that I'd like to build a conservatory or a
glass house and to design everything that
goes inside it.
[upbeat music with drum and guitar]
I think ideas come a great deal from being
alone.
And even though I work with a great team of
people all day long, I happen to be an early
riser.
So, I'm often up at four, five in the morning
and have several hours to be on my own and
think about things.
There's just all sorts of possibilities with
glass.
I can't think of too many materials that haven't
been exploited except for glass.
One night I melted some stained glass 'cause
I had this little kiln 'cause I was fusing
the glass together.
I put in a piece of iron pipe that I probably
bought at the hardware store, and blew a bubble.
I had never seen glass blowing before.
Like there was a picture on the wall.
I remember the picture clearly of a glassblower
with his cheeks all puffed out, like he was
blowing a trumpet.
So, from that point on, I wanted to be a glassblower.
[drum beats]
In 1971, myself and some friends started Pilchuck
Glass School.
Pilchuck Glass School really is what established
Seattle as the preeminent glass center of
the world--not just Seattle.
This is spread out into much of the Northwest.
And every summer, we went back to Pilchuck,
which was an experimental glass workshop.
It was kind of a school, but more than, I
would say more than anything, it was a place
where we developed ideas and experimented,
back when we didn't really care about sales
or anything like that.
So, nothing held us back from doing a lot
of experimentation.
The whole idea of making art, as far as I'm
concerned, it comes from just doing it over
and over and over.
We just have to be making a lot of mistakes.
And finally, you've just done so many thousands
of pieces that it becomes sort of natural
but you gotta go through five or ten years
of making mistakes all the time before you
can develop that.
[hissing]
Don't worry about the form quite so much.
Worry about the speed and worry about the
ease of the operation.
Once you get all of that going, then everything,
the form comes.
You got it down now.
Let's get it down.
Once we get it down, let's keep it there and
roll it.
Nice.
Over and over and over and over.
And then those forms will get better and better
and better.
I've been working with glass now for 40 years.
And, of course, the work started small.
And it got larger and larger.
And then, at a certain point, the pieces were
just big enough.
They became hard to handle if they were any
bigger.
And around that same time, I started architectural
installations.
I have a degree in interior design and architecture.
And so, that was very comfortable working
in the spaces.
Even my smaller objects often had--I think
of them as architectural because they'll have
one part inside another.
It was a very smooth transition to--.
The installation started small.
And then, as we learned how to put things
together, we quit making the parts big and
we went back to making the parts small.
And so, it's massing all that color together.
When you look at the sun, and there's a thousand
or more parts in it, there's that much yellow
and the sun is coming through it.
No artificial light is going through it.
It just, it's just a massive amount of yellow
color and it's in this big, simple form.
It just has a lot of power when you see it
in that way.
So, it was a natural thing for me to go from
the smaller works to the larger works.
[jazzy music]
I couldn't do one-tenth of what I'm doing
if I didn't have a big team.
So, the complexity of the big shows takes
a great deal of people.
And I've been very fortunate to, over the
years, build that team.
Maybe I got a little bit of that organizational
ability from my dad, the butcher that was
a union organizer.
I don't know what.
But I got very fortunate in being able to
work with great people.
[Spanish music]
I woke up one morning and said that I wanted
to hang chandeliers over the canals of Venice.
And then, from that came the concept of working
in different countries--making chandeliers
and taking them to Venice.
The first country was Finland.
The second was Ireland.
The third was Mexico.
[Spanish music]
It gave me an opportunity to build the chandeliers
or make installations.
And then, right outside, there were woods
or rivers to work in.
[splash]
And I always worked outside to some degree,
but since 1995, it's become a more important
part of my work.
[splash]
Three.
You take that idea, make the decision to go
with it and go down that road and see what
happens.
And sometimes, it doesn't work.
Most of the time, I've been fortunate that
a lot of the projects have worked or ideas
have worked.
[Spanish music]
>>Jeffrey Wright: My family and I have been
admirers of Dale and his work for many years.
And his art has been symbolizing to visitors--the
creativity and the inspiration that lives
and breathes in our city.
Dale has designed something truly beautiful
and inspiring for our community and the world.
And personally, I can't wait to see the finished
product.
[classical music]
>>Dale Chihuly: So, thanks again for coming.
See you here next spring.
[applause]
[end video]
>>Dale Chihuly: I guess it's springtime.
We're gonna open in 29 days, I think it is.
May 21st.
Right next to the Space Needle is about 100
feet over here and it's gonna be this long
building that's called the Exhibition Hall.
And that will have nine rooms inside the hall.
This is the glass house.
This is the garden.
[pause]
I'll go through a couple of the rooms with
you.
This is an installation I did in 1971 for
a museum in Switzerland.
And it's one of the first large-scale exhibition
that's about 30 feet across.
And I've always loved this piece, so I decided
to do it over for the project.
The next slide is the Northwest Indian room,
which is a take-off from a room that I have
in my studio in the boathouse in Seattle,
showing Pendleton Blankets, Northwest Coast
Indian baskets, Edward Curtis prints on the
wall that you can't see, and some of my glass
work that's influenced by the Indian baskets.
[pause]
The Glasshouse, by the way, we started this
project last August.
So, it's just gonna be--.
It'll take nine months from start to finish
on the project.
And the Glasshouse is just about finished.
You can see part of the piece that's gonna
be inside there.
It's the piece will be a hundred feet long
and 25 feet high inside the Glasshouse.
And then, you come out of the Glasshouse.
We went by the Temple of the Sun.
Over here is an installation of blue pieces.
[pause]
Now, we're gonna go to the Collection Café
where there's 28 different collections shown
in the Café.
There'll be 23 tables, each table having a
sheet of glass on top.
And you look down through it into a collection.
[pause]
Now, I'm gonna bring up my lovely wife, Leslie,
to talk to you about the partnering we're
doing with other institutions around the project.
[applause]
>>Leslie Chihuly: Got reverb?
It is all OK?
I hear a little something there.
It'll settle down.
I just wanna thank Google for inviting us
here today.
And I wanna thank you for the extraordinary
work that you're doing in featuring and championing
artists and creative thinkers by having talks
like this.
I know Dale did one before and we're just
very honored to be invited back.
So, thank you all for having us on the campus
today.
I'm Leslie Chihuly.
I'm president of Chihuly Studio and Portland
Press.
I'm also the Board Chair of the Seattle Symphony
Orchestra.
And like many of you, Dale and I are very
proud of the city we live in.
We wanna make a difference and we think that
this is really one of the great cities on
the planet.
It's a very special place in that it's big
enough to have a rich and diverse cultural
scene, and small enough where people feel
they can make a difference.
We're starters and builders.
Many of us in Seattle are newcomers drawn
by spectacular nature and beauty and kept
here by work, careers, families, and the opportunity
to participate in meaningful ways in the life
of the city.
With vision, talent, capital combined with
philanthropy and volunteerism, we have created
a community that attracts some of the best
and the brightest in the arts and technology,
medicine, business, and entrepreneurism.
We're celebrating the 50th Anniversary of
the World's Fair, where the builders and thinkers
of that time pointed to a bright future, full
of possibility, innovation, exploration, and
achievement.
In the last 50 years, Seattle has built the
cultural organizations we enjoy today.
Imagine Seattle and Tacoma without McCaw Hall,
Benaroya Hall, the restored Paramount, the
expanded Seattle Art Museum and the sculpture
park, the Tacoma Art Museum, Museum of Glass,
the Northwest African American Museum, the
Intiman, the Rep, the ACT--so many other museums,
galleries, and diverse organizations of all
sizes doing film, dance, music, and theater.
But another important anniversary is happening
right now, which you may not know of, which
is called the 50th Anniversary of the Studio
Glass Movement in this country.
A two thousand year old technology was about
to be turned upside-down and inside-out by
a small group of artists who began to experiment
with the natural qualities of hot glass.
They began to push the material beyond anything
that had ever been seen or done historically.
Testing and failing, being willing to try
over and over again to achieve new scale,
to use old techniques in new ways, gave birth
to a new movement and a new period in art
history.
We also celebrated the 40th Anniversary of
Pilchuck Glass School this past year.
It was co-founded by Dale.
And the school was built out of the dreams
of a few artists combined with the generosity
of philanthropists Annie and John Hauberg,
who decided to contribute lands and funds
to some young people who had ideas, energy,
and passion to create.
We're so proud that that school is going to
be one of the founding partners of Chihuly
Garden and Glass.
What you will see when you visit Chihuly Garden
and Glass is the work of a lifetime by a Northwest
artist.
It encompasses the education, the mentoring,
the influences, inspiration, travels and experience
of a lifetime spent looking at the world through
an artist's sensibility.
When the Wright family, owners of the Space
Needle, invited Dale as an artist to look
at the old Fun Forest site, they invited me
and our organization, Chihuly Studio, to participate
in the process.
We needed to make a case to the community
about how private use of public land would
be a benefit to the community as a whole.
Person by person, group by group, at City
Hall, in private and public gathering places,
we began to speak to the importance of this
project for kids, for fellow artists, for
tourists, for families, for the city, and
for the Seattle Center as a place where everyone
could come and see what is possible when you
have a commitment to making the world a more
beautiful and aesthetic place.
It says something about our city that we can
recognize how one person's success as an artist
means that others can have that same opportunity
to imagine new worlds and to see them take
shape in a lifetime.
We need to continuously support our arts.
We hope this project will provide more visibility
and success, not only to our founding non-profit
partners, which include Pratt Fine Arts Center,
Pilchuck Glass School, ArtsFund an the Seattle
Public Schools, but to all of the arts organizations
in the community who exist to serve the educational,
civic, and cultural needs of our city.
We hope that it is a window into the very
creative life of our city and that it is a
gathering place where more discussion and
more advocacy for what we value can happen.
Most of our arts organizations don't have
the endowments of older institutions around
the rest of the country.
So, our next push will be to endow the cultural
institutions we value so that we can sustain
them for the next generations.
Dale and I believe that exposure to the arts
should be a part of everyone's educational
experience, which is why we're excited about
Chihuly Garden and Glass and partnership that
it will have with the Seattle Public Schools.
A science curriculum is being developed for
all eighth graders in the Seattle area.
We believe that the understanding of creativity
within one's self and seeing it in others
helps to build community and translates into
more fulfilling and productive lives.
So, we need to continue to make the case for
arts in our community.
We don't take it for granted.
And we remember that is it our arts that give
the city its pulse.
With the help and thinking of the many creative,
innovative, and entrepreneurial members of
our community, many of whom are in this room
today and in the virtual room we're experiencing,
I imagine that we can be the leaders for the
rest of the world in terms of how to use our
existing public and private resources wisely
and to leverage those resources to a sustainable
future.
We hope Chihuly Garden and Glass will be a
source of joy and inspiration for everyone
in our city and that people who come to visit
from other cities and other countries around
the world will see that Seattle is a place
that supports its artists, its businesses,
and can dream big dreams and make them happen.
We invite everyone to go out and participate
in all kinds of arts experiences in the community--music,
screenings of theater, film, dance, and poetry.
And we see that the beauty of creativity is
that it enjoys many languages.
And the more people are exposed, the more
they can make connections and lead creative
lives in all fields of endeavor.
So, thank you so much for having us.
I wanna also introduce you today to Michelle
Bufano, who's the executive director of Chihuly
Garden and Glass.
And she'll join us for the Q and A.
[pause]
[applause]
>>Female Presenter: I wanna thank all of you
for taking time out of your busy schedule.
And I know just how busy it must be with just
23 to 29 days left here in the home stretch.
But to kick off, I wanted to talk a little
bit about the new project, Chihuly Garden
and Glass.
And it came up a bit in the video, but I'd
love to hear more about the inspiration behind
it, and also some of the challenges in Michelle's
day-to-day world.
So, Dale, maybe you can tell us a little bit
more about what inspired you around the project.
>>Dale Chihuly: Well, what inspired me was
to put together what I thought of was the
most important projects in my career.
So, it starts with 1971 and goes forward and
has one room of chandeliers from Venice.
And I just tried to make it as beautiful as
I could.
>>Female Presenter: And Michelle, you, as
the Executive Director of Chihuly Garden and
Glass, have been with this project every step
of the way.
So, tell us a little bit about your day-to-day
role and some of what you really look forward
to once the museum opens.
>>Michelle Bufano: Well, the main part of
what I've been doing is really focusing on
how each visitor will experience the exhibition.
So, from the second they get on our website,
which is up and running, to buying their tickets,
coming in the door, and how they experience
and interact with the art in all the different
levels--parts of the exhibitions.
So, it's been really exciting to watch the
art being installed and watch how it changes
every day and being able to react to that.
>>Female Presenter: And I think one of the
really interesting things about the exhibition
is that it brings together all these different
pieces of your career as well as an urban
landscape, as well as sustainable planning.
And I know that one of the things that's really
important to you is how your work is juxtaposed
against nature.
Has it been different working in an urban
space?
I mean, there's obviously some elements of
nature there, but I'm wondering what some
of the interesting challenges and opportunities
have been.
>>Dale Chihuly: It's been very different.
To start with, it was pavement six months
ago.
And Richard, our landscape designer, tried
to work with me with the installations that
would be there and then the landscaping that
would go with it, but it's, I'm not used to
working with landscape architects.
So, it was a challenge.
As you can see today, it's, some of the areas
look pretty good, but it's not gonna look
as good as it could for another year or so.
>>Female Presenter: I think that's one of
the great things about gardens, is that over
time, they grow and they change.
And so-- [laughs]
>>Leslie Chihuly: Yeah.
>>Female Presenter: I was lucky enough to
visit the site this morning and get to see
its progress.
And it's already just spectacularly beautiful.
So, it would be really exciting to see how
it comes out.
One of the other interesting pieces that's
different than other exhibits you've done
is the length of this exhibit.
You have the space for 30 years.
And I'm wondering if that's changed at all
your thoughts on how to lay it out and how
to design the exhibit because, rather than
just being there for one season, it's there
for a lot longer.
>>Dale Chihuly: Yeah.
It really changed everything.
We're used to having a show up for a month
or maybe three or four months.
But when it's gonna be up for 30 years, you
really have to make sure that it works.
And so, we made a lot of the glass specially
for that.
Like the piece that's up on the screen now,
we've done other works that have, made out
of these what I call Persian parts, but all
of these are like, twice as thick as they
would normally be just to make sure that there's
no way that anything could crack.
>>Female Presenter: And it's right there.
You can see it in the picture in the back
of this image if you can see the screen.
It's right there at the Space Needle, which
is celebrating its 50th Anniversary this year.
Were there parts of the exhibit that were
inspired by the Space Needle itself?
[pause]
>>Dale Chihuly: Probably.
[laughs] Yeah.
>>Female Presenter: I noticed there were a
lot of towers.
>>Dale Chihuly: I love that.
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
>>Dale Chihuly: You know, there are these
iconic towers in restaurants all over the
world.
And except for maybe the Eiffel Tower, this
is the tower that's most known.
I'm not quite sure why, but it, everybody
loves the Space Needle.
There was a time, 30 years ago, when people
wanted to take it down.
It was never meant to be up.
It was only supposed to be for the World's
Fair.
It cost three million dollars to build in
1962.
And last year, it cost four million dollars
to paint it.
[pause]
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: I think that happens a
lot with the World's Fair exhibits, the same
is true for the Eiffel Tower.
The Golden Gate Bridge, which I think was
also built for one of the World's Fairs, but
obviously, that was meant to be more permanent.
But tell us a little bit about your connection
to Seattle.
It's, you're almost synonymous with it.
I think each of you has your own special connection.
And I'd like to hear a little bit about, I
think this exhibit is really a celebration
of Seattle, itself.
And so, maybe you can talk a little bit about
your relationship with the city.
[pause]
>>Dale Chihuly: Well, I went to college in
Tacoma for the first year.
I didn't wanna go to school.
I was not a very good student.
My mother talked me into going to school.
And that winter, I decorated her basement
and thought I could be a great interior designer.
So, I transferred to the University of Washington
in Seattle.
And I got a degree in Interior Design and
Architecture.
And it was during that time that I was beginning
to work with glass and weaving and tapestries.
And one night, I melted some glass and blew
a bubble.
And from that point on, I wanted to be a glassblower.
And I went to Alaska and became a commercial
fisherman to save money to go to graduate
school at the University of Wisconsin.
And I went to Venice, Italy after that.
And I then went to the Rhode Island School
of Design to start a glass department there,
but at the same time, we started the Pilchuck
Glass School.
So, every summer, I would come back to Seattle
to Pilchuck and every winter, I would stay
in Rhode Island.
And I did that for ten years.
And when my sales of my glass matched my income
as a professor, which was 18 thousand dollars
a year in 1980, I quit teaching and came back
to Seattle and have been here ever since.
>>Female Presenter: And Leslie, I know you've
been working with numerous partners, some
of whom are, most of them are based here in
Seattle.
Maybe you can talk a little bit about your
connection to the city.
>>Leslie Chihuly: Sure.
Well, I moved here in '85 and went to graduate
school at U Dub in Russian Studies.
And at that time, you couldn't find a restaurant
that was open past nine.
We didn't have--.
I mentioned a lot of the halls and the things
that have happened really that have been built
since I moved here.
And I think what I saw was a city with a future,
the fact I didn't even think it really was
a city.
I thought it was a town.
And I think it's become a city in this period
of time.
And so, it's a really exuberant and hopeful
place in terms of being able to build and
do new things.
We're not burdened with a lot of the traditions
and history of older cities.
And so, it's a city where everything is possible.
What's exciting to me about this project in
the context of Seattle is not only the aesthetics
and the fact that we're celebrating a local
artist, as it were, but that we're going to
be a convening place for all of the arts and
for certainly the community partners.
And we hope that list will grow over time.
And I'm working with Michelle and many of
us are working hard to think about how the
space will be used over time to really bring
more attention to the incredible arts that
we enjoy in the city.
>>Female Presenter: And Michelle, you're now
the Executive Director of this exhibit that
really celebrates the city itself, some of
its wonderful landmarks, like the Space Needle.
Tell us a little bit about your experience
here in Seattle.
>>Michelle Bufano: Well, just to build on
what Leslie said about building our partnerships
with this city, and we're also building partnerships
on the campus--on the Seattle Center campus.
And it's really exciting right now because
of the 50th.
There's so much going on.
King Tut is opening in a month as well.
We have the symphony, the ballet.
But it's really becoming a focal point, the
whole campus.
And this project is spearheading a program
called "Center Nights," where people will,
everyone who's on campus will develop programming
and we'll open up our doors to great programming,
at least once a quarter for people to come.
So, I see it as really an opportunity to build
excitement and to bring people to one center
place for the arts.
So, that's been an exciting part of it.
Personally, I've been involved with Dale's
work since I worked at the Tacoma Art Museum
and then opened the Museum of Glass.
So, I've been a big fan of glass and most
recently came for Pratt Fine Arts Center,
which is one of the community partners for
this project.
>>Female Presenter: One of the interesting
things of the museum is there's a café.
And it's called Collections Café.
And I think that one of the things that really
surprised me when I got to visit the boathouse
was all the different collections that you
have, Dale--everything from shaving brushes
to accordions to Navajo blankets to something
I didn't even realize existed, but there were
string dispensers, which looked like little
faces on the wall with pieces of string coming
out of their mouths because before there were
tape dispensers, there were string dispensers.
And I know that collecting and just collecting
lots of different objects and looking at all
the differences is a big part of your process
as an artist.
So, tell us what some of the collections that
you're more proud of.
Maybe you want to give us a little bit of
background of the café and what people can
see there.
>>Dale Chihuly: Well, I mean, I started when
I was a kid.
But I think a lot of kids collect things--marbles
or toy soldiers or beach glass.
But I just kept collecting.
Usually, you stop at a certain age.
And I've always collected.
Like, I have 500 accordions and 800 Pendleton
blankets, 400 Northwest Coast Indian baskets.
And I was down at the Pacific Galleries this
weekend looking around.
I ended up buying four original posters of
the World's Fair from 1962.
And Leslie asks me sometimes, "What makes
you collect?"
I don't know.
I can't explain what it is exactly that makes
me--.
Some people like to collect.
Other people, it's a bother.
And the Collection Café was, we were gonna
have a café in the project no matter what.
And it was just the perfect opportunity to
get rid of some of those collections.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: So, I was there this morning
and you'll be able to see 28 of Dale's collections
up close, including, actually, inside the
tables.
So, each table will have its own collection
of some of the things that Dale has collected
over the years, everything from miniature
dogs to bottle openers.
There's antique radios.
There's a lot of really interesting artifacts
that come with the café part of the museum.
>>Dale Chihuly: And that's been a lot of fun.
We did a little--.
I'll tell you what.
We'll give everybody a little booklet.
But you don't get them today, but I did a
little catalog from about the café, showing
each collection.
And I printed 20 thousand of them to be given
away at the café.
And Leslie, no.
Yeah.
Leslie just told me today--
>>Leslie Chihuly: They're in.
They're in.
Big boxes full.
All right.
>>Dale Chihuly: they came in.
It costs 51 cents each to print.
[Female Presenter laughs]
>>Female Presenter: And I've heard they've
been a hot commodity.
There's been two proof books today that people
keep wanting to take with them.
So, it'll be interesting to see them, the
final product.
Your work really happens in series.
And you have some series for which you're
very well-known--the Macchia, the Venetians,
the Sea Forms.
Do you have one series that you really love
revisiting, or one that you like the best?
>>Dale Chihuly: Oh.
I've been asked that question before and I
don't really have a good answer.
It changes, you know?
Right now, I've been thinking about a series
that I started a few years ago called "The
Jerusalem Cylinders."
And in the next couple of weeks, we're gonna
start working on those again.
So, I'm thinking about Jerusalem Cylinders.
Right now, they're a favorite.
But sometimes, it's the baskets.
Sometimes, it's the Sea Forms.
It really does change because they were all--.
I thought about all of them before I ever
developed them into a series.
I didn't just say, "OK.
I'm gonna make baskets and then make, work
for two years on baskets."
I waited until I really felt that I had something
concrete before I pursued it.
So, it's hard to say.
I wish I could answer that better for you.
>>Female Presenter: And in the exhibit hall,
there's eight rooms.
And each of them map to one of the series.
And they have different themes.
One of the interesting pieces about the exhibit
is that it's in one of Seattle's highest traffic
areas.
>>Dale Chihuly: Thank you.
>>Female Presenter: Like, lots of people go
to the Space Needle.
You've been really putting the Garden and
Glass together with the public watching.
Have there been particular pieces in exhibits
that have been really hard to install?
Are there any good stories of assembly so
far?
>>Michelle Bufano: I don't know if we're allowed
to say those stories.
[laughter]
No.
I think you're--
>>Dale Chihuly: I'll tell you.
>>Michelle Bufano: looking at--
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
>>Michelle Bufano: one of the most challenging
right there.
>>Leslie Chihuly: That armature for the Glass
House was probably one of the most high-level
engineering feats of all time.
>>Dale Chihuly: That makes me think of that
story I told you this at lunchtime about difficult
situations, in that we blew glass in a little
village in France--Vion.
And we made, I had the whole team over there.
We had about 30 people working hand in hand
with the French glassblowers.
And we made enough glass to fill two containers,
which we sent back to Seattle.
Only one of the containers arrived.
The other went over the side of the ship.
And comes to find out that if you wanna ship
a container, if you want your container to
be below deck, you have to pay an extra tariff.
[laughter]
And somewhere, that container has got a lot
of bubble wrap in it.
So, I'll bet it's close to the surface somewhere.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: We talked that those containers
often float.
So, that's the hazard of doing work abroad.
But that said, I do think your time at University
of Wisconsin and Venice, more specifically
abroad, had really influenced your work.
Can you give us a little bit of insight into
how each of those locations has shaped your
work and your vision today?
>>Dale Chihuly: Well, let's see.
At the University of Wisconsin, I was coming
with a degree in Interior Design and Architecture.
I really hadn't made any art to say.
And so when I got there, I was gonna be in
a graduate fine arts program.
And I was really lucky to meet a couple of
guys that were far more talented than I was.
And I ended up, one of them was a roommate.
And during that year, I really learned a great
deal about art, not from my faculty, but from
these guys I was living with.
And that set me off in the right direction.
And when I went to the--.
What did you ask?
The Rhode Island School of Design?
>>Female Presenter: That or Venice.
Either one or both.
>>Dale Chihuly: Both.
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
>>Dale Chihuly: Well, either one.
I'll take Venice.
[laughter] Venice, I arrived in Venice.
I had a Fulbright, which pays, I think it
paid 450 dollars a month at that time.
And I arrived in Venice feeling a little depressed
from graduating.
And I finally made my way out to the Venini
Glass Works, one of the most famous glass
works.
And I had a letter from them saying that I
could observe there for three weeks.
And I met the owner and he had just gotten
a possibility of doing a commission--a large
commission--in a town square of Ferrara.
And they didn't have any experience or anybody
there that could really design something like
that.
And I talked him into letting me design it.
And I used glass.
I used plastic.
I used neon.
And so, I got set up.
I was given my own studio up on top of the
factory.
And there, I mean, I could have blown glass
there if I wanted to, but they were so much
better than I was.
It was too embarrassing.
But I got to watch all the time.
And that's really one of the best ways to
learn about glassblowing and a lot of other
skills, crafts, is by watching.
And I learned, 'cause back in the States,
everybody had been working by themselves.
And glassblowing doesn't work very well by
yourself.
It really takes a team of two or three.
We work with a minimum of about eight people
on the team at any one time.
And up as many as 15 people on a team, working
on the same piece of glass.
So, what I learned more than anything, what
I learned from Venice was teamwork.
>>Female Presenter: And in addition, you're
best known for glassblowing, but you also
paint and draw.
And one of my favorite things about Dale,
I don't know if you guys can see his shoes,
but he always has paint-smattered shoes.
[laughs] So, tell us a little bit about how
drawing and painting influences your inspirations
as an artist.
And how is that part of your process?
>>Dale Chihuly: Well, I never really drew
that much.
I mean, even though in undergraduate, I had
to make drawings of interiors and architecture.
After that, I never drew that much, but I
lost the sight of my eye in 1976, which meant
I had no peripheral vision and no depth perception.
And that made it difficult to work out there
with a team because for obvious reasons.
And so, from that point on, I started having
one of the really great glassblowers on the
team, a young man named William Morris.
I had Billy head up the team and I would make
drawings to show him what I wanted to make.
And so, that was back in the late '70s.
And I've been drawing and painting ever since.
A lot of times it won't be necessarily about
what I'm gonna make.
It'll just be, I just like to paint.
>>Female Presenter: I think one of the things
that had really, in addition to the scale
of your work, that really sets your work apart
is the thinness of the glass--how thin you're
able to blow it as well as the vibrancy of
the color.
And I imagine that some of those things are
advances that you've developed with your team.
Are there other technological advances that
have come along in the past 40 years that
have really changed glassblowing?
>>Dale Chihuly: Probably the thin glass, working
that way, was definitely innovative, but that
allowed us to--.
When it was thin like that, we could heat
it up in the furnace and it would begin to
collapse, or go asymmetrical.
Glass, if you let it go on its own, it wants
to be symmetrical.
So, if you're gonna make it like these pieces
here, are perfectly round and without having
that scalloped edge, until the last reheat.
Then, it's heated up and it's spun open.
They're about two feet in diameter--a little
more.
It's spun open and then it's spun harder.
And the tips, because it had been blown in
what we call an optical mold, which is a ribbed
mold, we blew it in there at a certain point,
which made the glass go thick and thin all
the way around.
And the thick parts remain hotter.
And so, they come out and you get that scalloped
effect.
And so, I suppose what I'm best known for
is asymmetrical glass using heat, fire, centrifugal
force, gravity.
Those are the tools.
We use very few hand tools.
>>Female Presenter: And I think with that
question, what your answer is really about
is about innovation.
And so, one of the questions I'd like to ask
all three of you is, are there things that
you've learned along the way through the partnerships,
through developing the exhibit, and also through
your work, through the many schools--Pilchuck,
Rhode Island School of Design--are there lessons
that you think could apply to tech and to
other industries, things you've learned along
the way that you think are true about pushing
a science or a medium forward?
>>Dale Chihuly: Well, probably teamwork.
[laughter]
>>Leslie Chihuly: I'm just thinking about
the new model that this Chihuly Garden and
Glass represents because it's really privately
owned and operated by the Wright family.
And it's called Wright Art, LLC.
And so, this is the first time that something
like this has been done in the city and yet,
we're partnering with non-profit groups.
We're not a non-profit.
We're not building a non-profit board.
We're not fund-raising.
So, the fact that it's been in private investment
by a leading family in the community is new.
And the fact that it's being done, in some
ways, to feel like a museum, to feel like
a non-profit, and the kinds of programs and
commitment that we have to community.
So, I think it's really a very innovative
approach to the organization.
>>Michelle Bufano: That's great.
>>Dale Chihuly: You know, the most important
of all is being creative, which is, would
be obviously critical to what you guys do.
And obviously critical to what I do.
And just being as innovative as you possibly
can.
Get up early and have a lot of ideas.
[laughter]
>>Michelle Bufano: So, as I've been reading,
though, about Dale's work, and preparing,
one thing is the way that you--you brought
it up earlier, Marissa--about he continues,
you continue to go back to a series and push
it a little bit further.
And the end result of that ends up being something
completely different maybe than you started
with ten years ago or 20 years ago.
And I think that is one thing that we could
all learn in our different disciplines that
we work in.
And it's that pushing it, but also coming
back to it, revisiting the idea again in a
different light.
>>Dale Chihuly: I wonder if, I touched on
this a minute ago, but if I'm starting off
a new series, let's just say it happens to
be these Persians.
And I'll work and I'll experiment and we'll
make them over and over, try different things.
Then, at a certain point, I have a month or
two worth of work.
And all through that process, I'm trying to
decide whether or not this work should become
a series for me, whether or not it's worth
investing the time and energy.
On the other hand, if I keep investing time
and energy into something that's gonna be
a loser, that's a big mistake.
And I have to decide at what point I cut it
loose, or at what point I decide that I'm
gonna exhibit it.
Once I exhibit it, it gets locked in.
And I would imagine that the same thing applies
to what you do to a certain degree.
>>Female Presenter: There's a lot of prototyping
and iteration in what we do.
And then also figuring out when are we going
to take something and really scale it.
>>Dale Chihuly: Yeah.
>>Female Presenter: It's the equivalent of
it, probably the technological equivalent
of having a series and when are we going to
just let an experiment go.
So, I'm gonna ask one more question, and then
we'll go to the audience for a few audience
questions, if you guys have some.
And my question is about, I think that this
piece that we're seeing here on the screen,
which is the Glass House and the new Garden
and Glass House, is really innovative and
it really is pushing the bounds.
And it is the centerpiece.
It's a hundred feet long, 40 feet tall, 14
hundred pieces of glass.
What was the inspiration here?
You said you always wanted to do it, but what
was it inspired by?
>>Dale Chihuly: Well, I always wanted to do
a glass house, which makes me think of a chapel
or a cathedral.
And I just designed the Glass House along
with what was gonna be inside.
And again, it was primarily to make something
that people hadn't seen before with the most
gorgeous color that I could do with the right
amount of work in the Glass House so that
it didn't get overpowered because I love the
structure as well.
>>Leslie Chihuly: One of our own--.
Well, you could talk about this, the armature
itself.
The structure of that was built in our studio.
And I think over all of the years of the projects
that Dale's worked on, that particular aspect
has gotten more and more sophisticated--the
engineering that goes into having something
that's a hundred feet long overhead, suspended
from glass is something that's really not
been done.
>>Female Presenter: I think one of the things
that Googlers can really relate to is, in
your work, there's a ton of engineering.
There's a lot of math.
There's a lot of geometry.
There's a lot of thinking through what will
work.
And so with that, I'd like to invite some
of the Googlers to ask questions.
Do we have any questions from the audience?
>>Dale Chihuly: One thing is that--you're
probably familiar with this--but if the chandelier
weighs, say, a thousand pounds--this one probably
weighs 25 thousand pounds--but if it weighed
a thousand pounds, we're gonna put it in Google
someplace.
The engineers wanna rate it to hold five thousand
pounds.
So, it's a five to one ratio, which is, which
can be a problem 'cause somebody wants a chandelier
in their house and it just won't support the,
what's required from engineering.
It would support it, but not the way the engineers
wanna support it.
>>Female Presenter: Well, I remember in some
of your Persian ceilings, I remember reading--I
was surprised by that the glass actually has
flex.
So, over these long expanses of glass that
other pieces of glass sit on, you actually,
you need a five foot piece.
You actually need five foot and a half an
inch because it actually will bow, which I
didn't realize the glass actually had that
much play and flexibility in it.
So, do we have a question?
>>male #1: So, this is a beautiful exhibit.
I have to know, what's next?
What other exhibits do you have in the pipeline?
[pause]
>>Dale Chihuly: Leslie, tell him what we're
doing.
[laughter]
>>Leslie Chihuly: Before we open this Chihuly
Garden and Glass, we've got a show at the
Dallas Arboretum coming up first week of May.
It'll be up through the summer, just during
tornado season.
So, we'll see how we fare on that.
And then in the fall, we've got Virginia Museum
of Fine Arts.
Coming up another, less than a year after
that is the Montreal Museum of Fine Arts.
And we're looking at some interesting projects
in Shanghai and in Beijing in terms of museum
shows and interesting exhibition opportunities.
[pause]
>>Dale Chihuly: Yeah.
Dallas will be the, I think it's the 12th
Arboretum or Conservatory show that I've done,
starting about ten years ago.
And that was a great deal to do because of
my interest in glass and glasshouses and greenhouses.
>>Female Presenter: You've talked a lot about
mentorship and teamwork, both the way you
were mentored early on by getting to watch
some of your fellow students and peers work.
There's a really happening, burgeoning art
scene here in Seattle.
How do you envision Chihuly Garden and Glass
and your studio interacting with that, with
that group of artists?
>>Leslie Chihuly: One factoid that we've mentioned
in the past, I don't know if you're aware,
but it's that we actually have more people
working in glass in the Seattle area than
in anywhere else in the world, including Morano.
So, this is the--.
And we've also got an MFA and a BA program
in glass now, the UW.
We've got the Pilchuck Glass School, which
I mentioned earlier.
So, there's a constant evolution of the educational
aspects that are possible for people in this
area at all ages.
We've got an at-risk glassblowing program
that's integrated into the Tacoma Public Schools,
called the Hilltop Program.
So, really at all ages, we're thinking about
glass and education around glass as an opportunity,
sort of as a lift-off point for creative thinking,
for working with your hands, for thinking
about ideas conceptually.
And who knows?
You think about the great history of glass
and what used to happen in Venice is that
if you escaped the island of Venice and you
made it to England with the secrets, you were
knighted.
But if you were caught leaving Venice, you
were beheaded.
So, Dale, one of his great innovations in
really generous gifts to the art community
is that he really opened up the community.
He opened up the secrets.
He invited the great glass masters of Venice
to come and work here.
And so now, there's this passing of the torch
that goes back and forth between the people
who've worked in glass for a long time and
those who are coming into it now.
>>Female Presenter: We have a few questions
here at the microphone.
>>female #1: So, something in the lines along
education.
So, you mentioned that you started out with
glassblowing pretty little.
How little were you?
And how little will be a kid to be old enough
to do glassblowing?
And do you have any advice for kids that are
too little?
What can they do at home or to start having
the creativity explored in them?
>>Dale Chihuly: Well, our son started blowing
glass when he was about eight.
Unfortunately, he quit when he was about ten.
[laughter]
But there are a couple of other kids that
blow glass at around eight or nine years old.
You can get quite good, actually.
Something they can do at a younger age is
to, it's what I did when I was in college
getting my degree.
And I started putting those bits of glass
in tapestries.
I needed to make it so that the glass wasn't
sharp.
So, I got a little oven, about two feet across,
that would go up to--.
It was a ceramic oven.
It went up to about 25 hundred degrees.
And so, I would put them in the oven and take
it up high enough to round the edges.
And then, I started putting one piece attached
to another, which is called fusing.
And then, I started working with making little
three-dimensional sculptures.
But you can have, I would imagine, you could
have probably from about the age of five,
you could have kids start working with stained
glass, or glass fusing.
Glass fusing would be easier, actually, than
stained glass.
You have to figure out at point can they cut
the glass.
Probably learn at a pretty young age.
Was that your question?
>>Female Presenter: We'll take one more question.
>>male #2: So, an exhibit like this probably
takes a lot of planning for light.
And how did you do that for, how do you plan
to have the lighting effect this exhibit when
it's not sunny in Seattle?
[laughter]
>>Dale Chihuly: I couldn't hear.
Could you hear it?
>>Leslie Chihuly: He's talking about light
and how did we plan it with the effect of
light, and--.
>>male #2: Yeah.
Like, you need a lot of light for something
like this to, with glass, right?
And--.
>>Michelle Bufano: I can tell you this.
At different times of the day, you have a
completely different experience in the Glass
House and the way that the light of the day
reflects on the glass that's in there.
What's so amazing about it is that it actually
changes as there's sun or no light.
It's just amazing to look at the different
qualities of the glass.
And I think that's one of the reasons people
will continue to keep coming back is just
to see that difference.
But as far as the planning goes, that was
all Dale's vision.
[laughs]
>>Dale Chihuly: You know, there are really
only three or four materials that transmit
light of any scale.
There are a few gems, like diamonds and things,
but materials of any scale there's only glass,
plastic--.
Actually, this is a good audience.
See if I'm wrong.
[laughter]
You got glass, plastic, ice, and water.
Those are--.
Alabaster would be one maybe.
Those are about the only material that light
can go through.
And that's what makes glass so incredibly
mysterious.
If you have a little bit of--.
If I put a piece of red glass on the wall
down there, a hundred feet down the other
end, one inch square, and I lit it from behind
with the sun or with a Par 36 light bulb,
you would easily see that one inch square.
Any other material, you couldn't even see
it.
There's something very magical about glass.
Did anybody think of another material?
See?
It's tough.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: Well, and actually going
through the exhibit today, I think that it
actually merits a few visits.
Like, I started noticing that at first, you
notice all the color and the shapes and the
forms.
And then, you start to realize how many different
lights there are here and there--the actual
engineering behind the exhibit, and the armatures
and things like that.
And so, I definitely encourage all of you
to go to Chihuly Garden and Glass when it
opens on May 23rd?
May 21st.
So, definitely encourage you to go visit,
make multiple visits.
There's a lot there to see.
It's like a combination of bringing together
an amazing career and a career that's still
in progress that I'm sure we're gonna see
even more great things from in the future.
And it's been a huge honor to have all of
you here today to talk about the project and
talk about your career and your accomplishments.
>>Dale Chihuly: It's our honor.
Thank you so much.
>>Leslie Chihuly: Thank you.
>>Michelle Bufano: Thank you.
[applause]